Traductor: Lidia Cámara de la Fuente
Revisor: Ciro Gomez
Comienza con una tos,
o una sibilancia.
Pronto, sientes el pecho apretado.
Tu respiración se acelera
y se vuelve más superficial,
haciendo que sientas que te falta el aire.
Estos son síntomas comunes
de un ataque de asma.
En todo el mundo, más de 300 millones
de personas sufren de asma,
y alrededor de 250 000 personas
mueren por asma cada año.
Pero ¿por qué la gente tiene asma y
por qué esta enfermedad puede ser mortal?
El asma afecta el sistema respiratorio,
particularmente
las vías aéreas más pequeñas,
como los bronquios y los bronquiolos.
Estas vías respiratorias tienen
un revestimiento interno llamado mucosa
rodeado por una capa de músculo liso.
Las personas con asma tienen las vías
respiratorias crónicamente inflamadas,
lo que les puede hacer hiperreactivos
ante ciertos desencadenantes.
Algunos de los muchos desencadenantes
del asma es el humo del tabaco,
el polen,
el polvo,
los perfumes,
el ejercicio,
el clima frío,
el estrés
y hasta el resfriado común.
Cuando las personas con asma están
expuestas a estos desencadenantes,
puede darse un ataque de asma
o su exacerbación.
Pero ¿cómo estos factores cotidianos
llevan a un ataque de asma?
Si un asmático está expuesto
a un desencadenante,
los anillos lisos del músculo que
circundan las pequeñas vías respiratorias
en sus pulmones se contraen y estrechan.
Simultáneamente, el desencadenante
empeora la inflamación,
haciendo que el revestimiento
de la mucosa se hinche más
y secrete más mucosidad.
Bajo condiciones normales,
el cuerpo utiliza este moco
para atrapar y limpiar las partículas,
como el polen o el polvo,
pero durante un ataque de asma,
bloquea
las vías respiratorias estrechadas,
haciendo aún más difícil respirar.
Estos efectos llevan
a estos síntomas del asma.
La constricción del músculo liso da
la sensación de opresión en el pecho.
El exceso de moco y el aumento
de la inflamación pueden causar tos.
Y ¿el ruido sibilante?
Eso sucede porque, como
las vías respiratorias se contraen,
el aire silba al pasar
a través del espacio estrecho.
Estos síntomas hacen que una persona
se sienta que se está quedando sin aire.
Sin embargo, contraituitivamente,
durante un ataque de asma,
la inflamación puede hacer
más difícil exhalar que inhalar.
Con el tiempo, esto conduce
a un exceso de aire en los pulmones,
un fenómeno conocido como hiperinflación.
El atrapamiento de aire en los pulmones
obliga al cuerpo a trabajar más duro
para mover el aire dentro
y fuera de ellos.
Con el tiempo, esto puede reducir el
envío de oxígeno a los órganos y tejidos.
A veces, en los ataques
de asma graves no tratados,
el cuerpo no lo puede aguantar,
lo que puede llevar
a la muerte por falta de oxígeno.
Pero ¿cómo podemos evitar estos ataques
incómodos y potencialmente mortales
en personas con asma?
Una forma es reducir
la presencia de desencadenantes.
Desafortunadamente,
el mundo es un lugar impredecible
y la exposición a los desencadenantes
no siempre se puede controlar.
Aquí es donde entran los inhaladores,
el tratamiento primario para el asma.
Estos medicamentos ayudan a asmáticos a
controlar y prevenir sus síntomas de asma.
Los inhaladores transportan medicamentos
a las vías respiratorias afectadas
usando una niebla líquida o polvo fino
para tratar el problema en su fuente.
Vienen en dos formas.
Hay medicamentos de alivio,
que tratan los síntomas inmediatamente
y contienen beta-agonistas.
Los beta-agonistas relajan
los músculos estrechados,
ensanchando las vías respiratorias
para que más aire pueda entrar
y salir de los pulmones.
Otros inhaladores sirven
como medicamentos preventivos,
tratando los síntomas
del asma a largo plazo,
y contienen corticosteroides.
Estos reducen la sensibilidad e
inflamación de las vías respiratorias,
manteniendo el asma bajo control.
También son cruciales
para prevenir daños a largo plazo
por la inflamación crónica,
que puede causar cicatrices
en las vías respiratorias.
Los inhaladores son conocidos
por ser muy eficaces,
y ayudan a mucha gente
a tener mayor calidad de vida.
A pesar del largo camino recorrido
para mejorar cómo tratamos
y diagnosticamos el asma,
todavía no sabemos sus causas exactas.
Hoy se cree que una combinación
de factores genéticos y ambientales
juegan un papel,
actuando potencialmente
durante la primera infancia.
Investigaciones recientes han relacionado
la pobreza con los ataques de asma.
Esto puede deberse a
la exposición a contaminantes
adicionales e irritantes ambientales,
a dificultades en la obtención
de atención médica o tratamiento.
A medida que nuestra comprensión
del asma mejora, seguiremos encontrando
mejores maneras de mantener las
vías respiratorias felices y saludables.